[Music]
for the first time ever new kids on the
block and new edition shared the stage
at the 2021 american music awards
me and the guys
all 11 of us on stage together
it's going to be incredible the boy band
and r b group faced off in an epic
battle of the boston bands both groups
famously hail from beantown
new kids on the block kicked off the
performance with their smash the right
stuff and new addition followed with
their hit candy girl
[Applause]
the two groups continued to trade hits
new kids cycling through step by step
please don't go girl and hang in tough
and new addition hitting back with mr
telephone man is this the end can you
stand the rain and if it isn't love
[Music]
the performance marked the first time
new edition has performed at the amas
since 1997 while it was the new kids
first ama performance in 11 years the
impressive medley of hits earned a
massive standing ovation from the crowd
and even got some stars in the audience
on their feet dancing
you guys you had everyone back here
dancing up on our feet and you had bts
up dance and you had the whole arena
dancing how'd that feel it was awesome i
was sitting there i'm dancing and i saw
them in there out there in the audience
rocking and i'm going yo what do they
know about this
after their collaboration on stage e.t
caught up with new edition where they
opened up about what a big moment this
was for both bands it was incredible you
know it's a moment that we've been
waiting for for a long time we love this
state the amas is great you know so be
up there with the new kids our hometown
shout out to maury stark he started both
groups out
so to be able to represent him and our
and on our city and go up there and
celebrate with our longtime friends new
kids on the block it was just a dream
come true for all of us and long overdue
yeah long overdue yeah as for whether
new edition plans to go on tour anytime
soon well fans should get excited
is this a prelude to you guys hitting
the road next year and this is what we
can expect we like it absolutely
absolutely we're working right now
as we speak to get everything nailed
down 20 22 we're on our way and we here
we come e.t also spoke with nko tb ahead
of the show where donnie wahlberg shared
why the history making performance feels
surreal being here is always fun but to
be here with new edition who are
means so much to us and and really paved
the way for us in all boy bands you know
it's kind of a boy band night here and
it wouldn't be right without the guys
who really paved the way the the real
guys who created the modern boy bed